Eh bien, je comprends pourquoi c'est le cas, je
fais des recherches sur la
durabilité des actifs cryptographiques depuis plusieurs années
maintenant et le fait est que chaque fois que vous
faites ce type de recherche, les chiffres
que vous allez trouver ne sont que
des actifs cryptographiques vraiment laids comme  bitcoin et ethereum
peuvent avoir un impact significatif sur le
monde si nous regardons simplement bitcoin et
ethereum combinés, nous voyons que
très récemment, ces deux étaient responsables
d'un pour cent de notre consommation mondiale totale
d'électricité et ce n'est que
la consommation d'énergie, alors nous devons penser
à  les émissions de carbone associées
à cela et celles-ci sont
également importantes en fait, les émissions de carbone
associées à ces systèmes
étaient très récemment plus de trois fois les
réductions mondiales totales de co2 des véhicules électriques,
nous n'en sommes même pas encore là, mais il y a plus
pour participer à  ces réseaux,
les gens utilisent généralement
des équipements hautement spécialisés, en particulier pour le
réseau bitcoin où vous ne pouvez
participer que si vous avez
des machines hautement spécialisées,
mais l'inconvénient de ces machines est
qu'elles ne peuvent pas être réutilisées et
les gens parcourent généralement très rapidement les
nouvelles générations d'appareils
qui aussi
nous laisse finalement avec un énorme tas de
déchets électroniques en fait j'ai quantifié combien
c'est et cela en soi est aussi juste pour
le réseau bitcoin autant que mon
pays d'origine les pays-bas produisent dans de
petits déchets d'équipement informatique chaque année
le
crypto cash qui va  est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'environnement dans le sens où
cela limite le montant
d'argent que les mineurs peuvent dépenser en
ressources. Les
mineurs de crypto-monnaie reçoivent un
montant fixe de pièces
pour chaque bloc qu'ils créent pour la
blockchain sous-jacente sur laquelle ils
exploitent si le  la valeur de ces pièces
diminue, vous ne gagnerez plus
autant d'argent qu'avant
et pour beaucoup de mineurs, cela signifie qu'ils
vont fermer leurs portes,
nous constatons que cela a un
effet assez important sur l'
énergie  l'utilisation et l'empreinte carbone
de l'ensemble du réseau qui a probablement
été réduite
d'un tiers
en quelques jours seulement